Democrats devour our cities that's the
focus of tonight's angle The Wall Street
Journal today published a searing piece
about the coming exodus from urban
America in just three months it has
become clear that modern urban
progressivism it's politically
incompetent and intellectually
incoherent the unhappy result as young
families and well-off retirees leave is
that these cities will be increasingly
becoming more divided between upscale
progressive singles able to afford the
political incompetence and the residents
of inner-city neighborhoods that will
fall further behind in March when the
kovat lockdowns began we saw how quickly
life in most big cities deteriorated now
mostly left-leaning mayor's prolong
their stay at home orders when common
sense screamed that doing so would only
create tidal waves of misery so when
schools and churches and community rec
centers closed there was little for
young people in the cities to do many of
them couldn't go to work or had been
laid off and what happened then
unemployment skyrocketed and the black
unemployment rate in May was the highest
in more than a decade at 16.8% the
horrific killing of George Floyd and the
outrage that it triggered was like a
match on dry kindling wood that was then
doused in rocket fuel political
arsonists encourage criminals then to
rampage through cities and spread fear
to the suburbs peaceful protesters were
used as cover for both antifa and BLM to
push a corrosive anti-law enforcement
narrative police precincts were overrun
as mayors and governors sat by just
twiddling their thumbs these urban
saboteurs are so desperate to rid
America of Trump they're so committed to
appending capitalism they'll sacrifice
anyone and anything along the way if
some innocent people have to die if some
family-owned businesses have to suffer
so be it in a few moments we'll hear how
a few are coping now the scenes I'm
about to show you are very disturbing
and they
all occurred in American cities were
racial hatred and anti-police sentiment
is being allowed to fester and grow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one of the other networks not run any of
that now we're already seeing a massive
wave of crime sweep across our major
cities in the last 28 days New York City
has seen the number of murders double
from last year's figures from 19 to 38
shootings are up 24% burglaries 47% car
thefts 60% misses all despite the
lockdowns which the experts told us
would reduce crime other cities are
plagued by violence as well LA that's
where we are police reporting that
murders are up and get this how much two
hundred and fifty percent just in the
first week of June and as riots gripped
Chicago the Windy City saw its deadliest
day in 60 years when on May 31st 18
people were killed in just 24 hours
most of them African American major
media outlets do not cover these facts
why yet if a cop tases someone who is
resisting arrest
you're gonna see every camera angle why
our Democrats and members of the media
excusing wanton acts of violence by some
to further a particular political agenda
of course they are here's how the bright
minds at CNN rationalized Rashard Brooks
decision to attack Atlanta police
officers mr. Brooks was known by them to
not have a weapon other than the Taser
that he had taken from them there's a
lot of chitchat a lot of niceties for a
long time what about the benign option
of the guy says he's gonna walk home why
not giving him the option of letting him
leave that way he was driving drunk okay
local and state politicians in both
parties are too afraid or too weak to
face the truth America has an intense
spiritual and family problem not
systemic racism and policing for too
long we also had an economic system that
helped multinational companies at the
expense of working people so instead of
address
these very difficult problems the media
they want to convince kids that the
entire criminal justice system is itself
inherently abusive toward one group of
people now you bet racism exists in the
country and so does cynicism the type of
cynicism that says that black kids and
their families don't deserve to have a
choice in education and they don't
deserve to have what their jobs stay
here instead of being shipped overseas
what the left is proposing and what
Biden is promising would be disastrous
for all but I'm telling you for African
Americans they would suffer the most
their economic policy would not only
hamper job creation in the United States
it would restart the efforts to ship
jobs offshore so economic and wage
growth will stagnate of course what will
happen
China will profit though now wealthy
people like billionaires and
millionaires finding Biden's campaign
they could benefit from all those
policies after all many of them own the
companies that want to take jobs from
here and send them over there and they
want foreigners more of them who will
accept lower wages here in the United
States and by the way those same rare
rich people can avoid some of the
harmful effects of left-wing policies
but by doing what they've done in the
past fleeing the cities for the suburbs
there they will have probably plenty of
police and there they will be able to
send their kids to private schools and
work at decent jobs all from the comfort
of home but poor people of all races
especially the ones stuck in cities they
work at essential jobs and they'll pay
the price I could
being completely just shattered as her
husband Ralph was trying to clean up
outside Alvarez says she turned to see
him on the ground in front of a large
crowd unconscious I started to scream I
tried to wake him he wouldn't wake back
up and I tried to call for the police
you know what speaking up no one was
picking up it doesn't have to be this
way
president Trump has shown that he will
fight and beat the business lobbies who
don't want to pay decent wages to
American workers
unlike Biden he'll actually stand up to
the pro-china lobby and keep good jobs
here at home
and unlike Biden he'll fight crime and
he'll work to keep our city safe and
vibrant for all
unlike Biden he'll resist efforts to
drag America into useless Wars just ask
John Bolton and his party stands with
him the reason the left keeps bringing
up ancient history is because today's
GOP is ready willing and eager to work
with african-americans we want to
empower them and we want them to make a
major part of a makeup the major part of
the GOP coalition any claim to the
contrary is a lie and it's toxic and we
won't stand for it
but Democrats have nothing substantive
to offer which is why they do everything
possible to insult african-americans
like Tim Scott who takes leadership
roles in the GOP and takes them very
seriously for the last 60 years American
liberals have promised African Americans
that their policies would make things
better they were wrong and their
policies have failed miserably that's
why the left has to spread hatred and
division division and that's why they're
lying about this country and its history
they have nothing positive to offer
today their only hope is to persuade
Americans to give up and turn on each
other
if you've observed recurring violations
of the safer at home order please
continue to let us know in this case
snitches get rewards we still know
there's some people need to get the
message and that means sometimes making
sure the enforcement is there to educate
people everyone will say well you know
I'm not a racist yeah great
and that's not good enough we have to
resist these efforts to divide and
snitch on and demonize fellow citizens
or our cities will be lost and we will
never find the unity we were created to
achieve and that's the angle